ever since russia invaded ukraine much
of the western world has bombarded them
with restrictions boycotts and sanctions
for example the biggest companies in the
world including apple amazon adobe
netflix and disney have all stopped
operations in russia
similarly many countries have stopped
importing russian oil and some countries
won't even let russian aircraft fly over
them not to mention most russian banks
and accounts have been completely frozen
the idea was that we could help ukraine
by hurting russia economically and that
an economic crash would cause russia to
back out faster but so far this doesn't
seem to be the case the russian economy
is indeed hurting but the russian ruble
is actually stronger than ever and if
you don't believe me just take a look at
the charts
initially the ruble did crash 50 as soon
as the sanctions were implemented but
since then the rule ball has skyrocketed
150 percent this means that the ruble is
currently the strongest it's been in
seven years now you might be thinking
that this must be because the dollar is
performing even worse or something like
that but this isn't the case either in
fact the dollar is the strongest it's
been in 20 years on a relative basis and
this just makes it even more significant
that the russian rupaul is skyrocketing
against the dollar
so what in the world is happening with
the russian ruble and why is it mooning
despite the sanctions
one of the top reasons that the ruble is
doing so well is because many of the
sanctions imposed on russia aren't even
that effective especially the energy
sanctions you see the european union is
way more dependent on russian energy
than they would like to admit and though
i'm sure many of them would like to ban
russian imports completely this is
simply not realistic here's the thing
russia is the world's largest gas
exporter and the second largest oil
exporter so it's not really possible to
completely cut off russian exports
overnight if they did do this it would
be the countries that are importing oil
that would collapse first but wait a
minute didn't the eu implement a russian
oil embargo
well the answer is yes but there's a lot
of fine print and exceptions
first of all the goal is to ban most
imports by the end of the year not by
tomorrow also certain countries like
slovenia and hungary are partially or
even completely exempt from the embargo
such countries are not only extremely
dependent on russian exports but more
importantly their landlord meaning that
they can't receive oil through the sea
these countries primarily get their oil
through pipelines directly from russia
and as you would guess rebuilding such
infrastructure would take several years
if not well over a decade and given that
most western countries are already
headed towards the recession completely
operating their crude oil source is the
last thing these countries want to do
and given that oil prices are
skyrocketing as well energy exports have
just become even more profitable for
russia in fact during their first
hundred days of the war it's estimated
that russia pulled in 60 billion worth
of revenue from fossil fuel exports to
the eu alone also let's not forget that
not every country is against russia most
of us are constantly exposed to western
media so it seems like the entire world
is against russia but this isn't true by
any means many countries actually
support russia including belarus cuba
nicaragua venezuela and kyrgyzstan but
you don't even have to support russia to
help them if you simply stay neutral and
continue importing russian oil that
itself is a massive benefit for russia
and this is exactly what many countries
have been doing particularly china and
india these countries have no financial
reason to stop importing russian energy
in fact they're incentivized to import
more
you see it as western countries slowly
step away from russian energy the price
of russian energy decreases and this
gives countries like china and india the
perfect opportunity to buy for a
discount and that's exactly what they've
been doing china has risen to be
russia's top all-importer having bought
12.6 billion worth of oil since the war
started meanwhile india has transitioned
from being an occasional buyer to being
a consistent buyer before the war
started india imported well below 5
million barrels of oil from russia on a
monthly basis and many months were even
zero but now india is importing tens of
millions of barrels every month and as
more time passes i think it just becomes
even more likely that more countries are
adopted to policy it's not that they
support the war rather they're simply
gonna do what's in their best interest
and if russia has the cheapest oil then
so be it
aside from western sanctions being
negated by exemptions and neutral
countries the ruble is also
substantially benefiting from supply and
demand while we like to throw around a
bunch of fancy terms like quantitative
easing when describing a country's
currency or economy in the end the
currency strength just comes down to
supply and demand if demand outpaces
apply then the currency will gain
dominance conversely if supply outpaces
demand then the currency will lose
dominance western countries were
obviously trying to accomplish the
latter by eliminating demand but this
has sort of backfired as we just
discussed russia is still able to find
significant amounts of demand for their
oil which in turns means that rubol is
in high demand however the supply of
rubles has gone down substantially
because almost every western company you
can think of has left russia so russians
are no longer giving rubles to foreign
companies if you haven't noticed yet
this means that rubles are entering
russia but not leaving russia russia has
actually leaned into this by
implementing a slew of different rules
for example putin has declared that
importing countries must pay for russian
oil and natural gas using rubles
similarly russian exporters are required
to convert at least half of their excess
revenues into rubles these rules stretch
further than just exports and imports as
well
for instance russia has banned foreign
stock and bondholders from taking their
dividend payments out of russia all of
these policies have just further
inflated the demand for the ruble while
also defining the supply of the ruble
and simple economics would tell you that
this is extremely beneficial for the
ruble not to mention russians themselves
are extremely reluctant to let go of
their rubles because they can earn
extraordinarily high interest rates by
just leaving it in the bank when the war
started russia hiked interest rates all
the way to 20 percent they have since
decreased them to 10
but as long as the currency itself is
holding strong there is very little
reason to seek out investments or spend
your money when you can just earn 10
doing nothing russia has actually
started to lighten such monetary
policies because they don't want the
robot to get too strong you see it if
the rubric continues to get stronger
exports from the country will become
less and less appealing and that's the
last thing russia wants right now so
ironically the ruble is starting to get
so strong that even russia is okay with
a slight cooldown
listening to all of this it might seem
like western sanctions were a massive
fail and from one perspective they were
after all russia is still making loads
of money and the currency is stronger
than ever but it's not all sunshines and
rainbows while russia has plenty of
money to spend it they can't actually
spend it here's the thing while
sanctions may not have been that
effective at stopping countries from
buying russian products they have been
quite successful at preventing russia
from buying foreign products a great
example of this is car sales russia
expects car sales to half by the end of
this year another example is
semiconductors in fact the supply of
semiconductors has gotten so bad in
russia that they have started to use
dishwasher and refrigerator chips inside
military equipment this isn't that
surprising when you consider that u.s
technology exports to russia have
decreased by 70 since the start of the
war this is the same case with
telecommunications lasers avionics and
maritime technology as well and while
russia may be able to put up a strong
facade in the short term it's only a
matter of time until these internal
shortages start destroying not just the
economy but their entire society but
wait a minute doesn't everything get
produced in china why don't chinese
companies just supply russians with
semiconductors and phones and cars not
to mention it they could probably charge
the russians a premium for this right
well they definitely could but none of
the big chinese companies really want to
do this this isn't to say that these
companies support ukraine but at the
same time helping russia isn't in their
best interest either here's the thing
these manufacturing companies have been
selling large contracts with american
juggernauts like apple and nvidia and
the last thing they want to do is
jeopardize their contracts with these
companies by selling equipment to russia
it's simply not worth the risk this
isn't to say that no one is helping
russia though many smaller companies
that don't have relationships with
western countries and companies are
willing to help russia but as you would
guess these are almost always second
grade products so the longer the
sanctions go on the more likely it is
that russia's technology will degrade
aside from facing a supply crisis russia
is also facing a debt crisis recently
russia missed a bond interest payment
not because they couldn't afford it but
because they couldn't pay you see the
interest payments were supposed to be in
euros and dollars but russia doesn't
really have access to these currencies
so they tried paying with rubles but
this payment was blocked by
international sanctions considering this
missing the payment isn't exactly
russia's fault but this will no doubt
discourage investors from buying russian
bonds which will just make it even
harder for russia to get through this
war so while the rule bullet is stronger
than ever the same cannot be said about
the russian economy
in the end russia has played the
sanctions game as well as they can
they've found a new buyers for their oil
they've limited the outflow of rubles
and they've successfully stabilized the
currency all of these efforts have kept
russian income rather consistent but
this isn't to say that russia is winning
the economic war while russia has plenty
of money to spend it they literally
can't spend it they can't buy cars or
phones or computers or really anything
they're forced to rely on chinese
knockoffs that don't have anything to
lose by working with them this hasn't
become that big of a problem yet given
that the sanctions have only been in
place for a few months but imagine what
happens five years down the line what
will everyday russians do when they need
a new car or a new computer russia's
tech industry has already realized this
and that's why tens of thousands of tech
workers have been fleeing the country
and as these tech workers flee the
country it just becomes even less likely
that russia is able to reproduce russian
technology by themselves and in today's
world where technology is basically an
essential russia will only be able to
keep up the trade for so long until
something gives so yes the russian ruble
is indeed the best performing currency
of 2022 but in the end the entire point
of a currency is to act as a medium of
exchange and the given that the
ruleballer is feeling it doing just that
its relative strength is all but
meaningful but that's just what i think
how much longer do you think russia can
keep up this charade comment that down
below
also drop a like if you thought this
video explained the rebel situation well
and of course consider checking out our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing and
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you